hard choices make an easy life right how
is this well I learned that from one of
my my teachers and and it really makes
sense is that if you make hard choices
in life
which is uh leaving a bad relationship
moving uh telling someone what you what
you really want hard choices you'll end
up with an easier life if you make easy
choices you have a hard life and that's
true if you just go along with things
that you don't really want to do it kind
of you know if you have a job that you
hate if you don't stand up for what you
want sort of easy choices you kind of
have a heart of life so I totally
believe that we need to make hard
choices and sometimes
saying things to a partner or leaving a
bad relationship or leaving a job that's
killing your soul
if you do some of that you'll have a
better life
can you give us some examples of how you
made one or two hard choices and how it
turned out
um beneficially let's see high choices
well
I was very successful in New York
and working all the time you know and I
was teaching there too and then we said
you know what let's go to La I really
wanted to go to La I wanted to make
movies I had done a film with Barry
Levinson and that was a hard choice
because we had to get up and move and
when I came to La the first couple of
years I had no work I had no anything
but that hard Choice got me the greatest
life I could imagine I mean I've had
such a wonderful time here in other
words I was willing to take risks that
were difficult because everybody says
where are you going I mean I was working
in New York I was doing this I was doing
that so we make we make hard choices uh
in life and it could be also personal
choices where you go like no this
relationship isn't exactly what I'm
looking for so you move on but there's
always hard choices to be made
if you make hard choices you usually end
up in a much better place
I mean heart choices is what Steve Jobs
did
they turned him down they said computers
don't it's not gonna you know nobody
wants to make your computers
so he made his own computers you don't
think that was a hard Choice he had to
put his own money into it in the garage
hard choices is
um as we say it takes pressure
to make a diamond and you have to enjoy
that kind of pressure
to become great at anything you have to
enjoy the pressure
once he was successful he was then
ousted from his own company yeah as well
so he has many different parts
absolutely yeah yeah absolutely what I
mean what I like to focus on is I like
to focus on
success has Clues and what I'd like to
focus on is helping people from artists
to Ordinary People how to have a more
successful life because I think there's
no question that the world wants you to
be like everyone else
I think that it's all about uh you know
blending in
and being average I don't think the
world is not striving for your
individuality I think the only city I
know is that we like individuals is Los
Angeles if you're like different and you
have different ideas La likes that La is
also a town where
we don't sit around and complain we
don't say oh you don't then I'm you know
you don't sit around waiting for them to
hire you for a movie We're big on
creating your own opportunities and
that's something that I'm very a very
big you know believer in and teach
people help them design something
because we don't see sort of sit around
it's for people that want more in their
life and they would like to achieve more
and they just that's something they
desire and that's what I I always
desired I like having more and going
more and meeting more people
and making a bigger difference I always
enjoyed doing that after you left New
York and came to La when did you sort of
say you know what this was worth it that
you know I realized this was a hard
choice but it actually paid off was
there an aha moment you got a job booked
up I think I think it was like two years
later two years I got a job on a TV show
I got a job to coach somebody finally
that I really liked you know because I
started coming to La was starting fresh
brand new no one had ever didn't know
who I was you know never never
department and I thought Let's Take On
The Challenge you know some people
the more you risk the more you can
succeed if you don't take any risks
nothing happens
um and I think that taking risks as part
of this part of life
and I think that the more risk you have
the more enjoyable life you will have
was there a moment in your career or two
where you were close to giving up
close to giving up uh
no I never I never was I mean I thought
gee because in the beginning it's so
hard but no I I decided I was going to
be an actor no matter what I was not
going to give up no matter I had that
kind of personality where I was like no
even when nothing was going on I was
like I was going to stay and I was going
to be become a great actor I don't know
how long it was going to take me but I
was going to do that
and uh I feel like I've sort of achieved
that now in the last couple years really
it took a long time
but um yeah I was never no I never I
never thought of ever giving up
what are your thoughts on playing it
safe and what is playing it safe
what does that look like well there are
if you're speaking about acting
let's let's say this
uh there are actors and they're artists
actors play the part exactly how people
expect you to play it artists are people
who don't play that role in any way you
think they would have played it and they
play differently and they become iconic
and people really uh enjoy it if there's
any what part of a movie do you enjoy
give me something I just saw Empire of
light and the entire movie had me from
the opening Beautiful film it was about
loneliness the cinema and and believing
that you were okay even if the world
told you that you're not right but with
any other role that you can think of a
movie that you liked any kind of a part
that movie that an actor that you're
liked in a movie oh well I love Kate
Blanchett I loved her in Blue Jasmine
especially so that's it and so there you
have that you have there's so many roles
usually it usually any kind of role that
you love is because they played it in
such a unique and different way that it
stood out to you it's sort of like a
pizza most time you get pizza pizza and
then you go like oh my God this is
different and the artist that I work
with uh are interested in making choices
that are different and unusual if you
start from like a Silence of the Lambs
that's an example
um Anthony Hopkins how would most people
play that I mean he's supposed to be a
guy that eats people he's in he's in a
jail and some people would have played
it like wild and you know like like a
gorilla or something like I don't know
but he played a very casual
very elegant
with music Opera
he was very contained and certainly
that's what people like people like to
be thrown where they can't really
anticipate the kind of character that
you're playing
who do you like aside from Anthony
Hopkins well I like so many I mean I
start with Marlon Brando everything
starts with Mile and Brando I like Mom
Brando I like a lot of different actors
for different roles
of course you know Meryl Streep you
can't you know can't go wrong there
she's so amazing there are people who
are gifted who take acting to the next
level and that's what I like to think
about is that I'd like to train my
actors to become actors of the future
because the audience wants more all the
time the audience doesn't want the same
acting if you look at the movies from
the 40s they don't want that acting
anymore and things change 50s and 60s
and now it's even more than you have
then you have of course Dustin Hoffman
some of his performances but they're you
know there are different actors I like
for different roles Anthony uh Sydney
portier I like him too but what I like
is just something that I'm impressed
with their artistry
but everybody can like you know that's a
personal choice
how does someone know if they're not
taking enough risks in their life well
if you're not
uh achieving your goals you're not
taking enough risks I mean risks have to
be taken and basically you can play it
safe
uh and but the people that win are the
ones who take risks watch watch football
watch any sport people are taking more
risks when they go like listen
uh and if you feel like you're not
achieving enough you're you need to take
more risks but it's also important that
you have a mentor because sometimes
people are just doing all kinds of
things that are not producing the
results they want that's really the
thing it's about results
and uh I would say that having a mentor
or coach or someone who's achieved what
you're looking for
uh is super important if you want to
have success in some sort of Industry
get someone who's the number one person
in that industry
uh you know they they know how to
achieve it because most people just
don't and so you need help I would say
that all successful people I know in
every field always ask for help average
people don't but successful people
always ask for help which is I'm sure
what you do when your car is broken you
get you know you're not fixing it
yourself or if you don't feel good I'm
gonna go to a doctor we always ask for
help but successful people that I know
some big stars are always asking for
help